eric says best channel best speakers by
bitcoin g money says robert can you tell
us a big secret behind green initiatives
and the move to carbon based currency
and your thoughts on a us social credit
score there's a few questions there so
let's talk about them let's talk about
the u.s social credit score first what
do you think of that question
well i think it's called what
surveillance capitalism
and that's why you know my friend has
with syrian alexa and all that stuff
i want
i want a little bit of that stuff around
me as possible
and so i know they're tracking i know
they're going to track us on this
program
and that's called censorship if you know
what i mean
and it's the worst thing is
self-censorship
because i'm so afraid what youtube's
going to do to me or twitter is going to
do to me i self
censor
and that's called fascism
yeah
yeah yeah i've got a self-censor as well
too and i'm casting like i know that
there's certain things i can't say in
certain areas that i won't go to and i
just reserve that for
off off-air stuff right correct when
having did our one-on-one and stuff like
that can't be censored
well
it's all but this is the thing rich
there's always the outside
know we cannot control the outside that
well
but we can't control this inside and
that was the thing i learned in the
marine corps can i be
a leader meant my own brain
my own emotions my own spirituality and
my own physicalness i can control me so
i'm a leader inside of me
and that's why what your you and rallo
are saying really strengthened this for
me
because i was getting my ass kicked by
women
and my weight physically
you know i had lost control here
so like i said i was i was now it wasn't
it was a double l ralph lauren shirt and
a 40 inch waist
i think that the um notion of the u.s
social credit score that this guy's
referencing is probably along the lines
of what's unfolding now that's starting
to look like what china's been doing
where it's like if you know if your
credit's not good enough if you go
outside and do something that's not a
that's not agreeable to the government
or you haven't been vaccinated you know
for example you haven't taken certain
shots and you lose certain privileges
like even right now in canada you could
argue that there's a social credit score
because i can't get on a plane and
travel because i haven't taken a
government vaccine right so i mean there
is a a social credit score that's
starting to unfold here like if you
started to see that happening more or
well i i was in dallas texas with gammon
and i said yea though i'll walk to the
valley of the shadow of death i shall
fear no evil
because i have my own private jet and my
money stashed offshore
[Laughter]
it's a lesson there guys money solves a
lot of problems for you
and i have i'm going to get a second
passport yeah john i mean i second
passports are a very very good idea i
was actually i had a guy on david
lesperance he's an ex-lawyer that lives
in poland he's a canadian guy and he was
telling me and he's breaking down all
these reasons and all these examples and
it was on this cast too so so it's on
this playlist on playing the win
and he was breaking down the reasons for
second third passports you know how your
ass doesn't need to be where your assets
are like you can have your assets
another country in your ass somewhere
else sort of thing
very very good concept if you guys
haven't seen that you know go watch it
because it's an introductory into it i'm
going to have david on again in the
future too by the way
um
uh sorry he so g money here said uh the
big secret behind green initiatives and
the move to carbon-based currency so
what are your thoughts on on that part
of the question well god bless alc
alexandra ocasio-cortez that's climbing
that's prince
well when she came with she came out
with you know she came up with two
things
with the green the green new deal i
don't know if she came up with it and
then taxed her rich
right so i said okay look at that and a
capitalist can figure that if you can't
out-think a socialist or a communist
hang it up man
you know capitalists are capitalists
because they're very creative
individuals
so i called my other friend he's talking
to me and says i'm going to start a
carbon credit company
well the alc is driving everybody into
carbon credits they've been been around
for 20 years yeah so i just made another
couple of million dollars because i
financed a carbon credit deal yeah
everybody has to buy carbon credits for
me
god bless aoc
[Laughter]
and you know just go and and a carbon
credit is really a tax on like exxon and
the airlines and all this
what happens now is
delta airlines has to buy carbon credits
for me
god bless them do you think that the um
carbon credit social credit system
that's coming
i can't remember who did this tweet it
was a guy from sweden and it said
something along the lines of it's you
know the year is 2032. um you get into
your electric car which won't go
anywhere because you've already utilized
your mileage for the month and exceeded
your carbon credits you then walk to the
grocery store to pick up your groceries
and some steaks and they won't let you
check out with your steaks because
you've exceeded your carbon credits so
you have to go home with a bag full of
bugs
and that's your dinner like it could get
to that point could it not like don't
you think
you never know rich you never know i
mean
i wrote rich dad porter in 97 i gave my
crack a cash flow board game
which this is part of it you know it's a
financial statement
okay you got to have a financial
statement today most people don't have
one
the reason i can borrow so much money is
because of that but that's my way of
saying
in 96 97 i knew was going to get worse
because i flew behind enemy lines in
1972 to buy gold
i paid 50 bucks for it that was a lot of
money back then for marine lieutenant
you know
i didn't think rich i didn't think it
was going to get this bad
you know so it's kind of a lot worse
than i imagined so is it going to get
worse possibly
but i'm preparing for it not
not you know hiding in a bunker if you
know what i mean
i'd rather be like a patent on the front
line general patton
than a bunker bunny general hiding
behind the afraid of afraid of a gunfire
life life seems to be a a series of
problems and challenges you know
especially for men and i've always said
to guys you know what they asked me like
you know when it comes to
entrepreneurship rich like what do you
think is the number one trait that you
should have and i've always said problem
solving skills problem solving skills
because that's because that's what being
an entrepreneur is you've got to solve
problems constantly
how how important is being able to solve
problems when they come at you in life
well again as skill sets it's what skill
sets do you need to solve the problem
like you know if uh somebody has a
plumbing problem i can't solve it for
them
i'm not a plumber right but finance i
understood so that's why
i studied i've been studying money since
i was nine years old i've been studying
the fed
since i met the creature from jackal
island by george griffin
and in my book coming out the fit is
actually marxist but people don't know
that
which goes back to what i studied at the
academy the communist manifesto marx and
leonard said a central bank
is essential to communism
and this is the third central bank is
the fed you guys have the you know
canadian bank you have the european
central bank and all this
and they control the show
well that's why i have gold silver and
bitcoin because i don't trust them yeah
you have to deal with them
but you don't have to be a victim of
them
yeah you can structure your life in such
a way where you're not under their thumb
all the time
you